- When I'm drawing,
It's one of the rare times
where I'm kind of focused and
feel like the world
slows down.
- I'm Joel Crawford, the director
of Puss in Boots: The Last Wish.
- Hi, I'm Domee Shi,
the director
and co-writer of Turning Red.
- I'm Chris Williams.
I’m the writer
and director of The Sea Beast.
- My name is João Gonzalez.
I'm the director,
animator, writer
and composer of
Ice Merchants,
and today I'm going to be
drawing my characters,
receiving an Oscar.
- And today
I'm going to draw
Jacob Holland
winning an Oscar.
- And today
I'm going to be drawing
Puss in Boots,
receiving an Oscar.
- I will be drawing
my character, Meilin Lee
receiving an Oscar.
My definitive drawing
point would be like the head
the tilt, the angle
and kind of like the
expression of the character.
- I find it's usually good
to start with the cranium,
figure out that line of action
through the middle
of the character.
- What I love
about Puss in Boots
is that there's this charisma,
but underneath it all, he's
a cat that's wearing boots.
Maybe the light that's
reflecting off of the Oscar
creating kind of like
a laser pointer effect,
would totally distract
Puss in Boots,
and he can't help but
c-c-c-cat like chase after it.
- So with these characters,
for me,
the most important part
was really to emphasize
the father son relationship.
That's why
I believe I also chose to exaggerate their proportions.
For example,
the father having very,
very long
legs and the kid being
quite small.
It was very important
for me to establish that
very nice relationship
they have going.
- It was a challenge for us,
especially in this movie,
because a lot of things
that are associated
with being a tween
girl are very expensive
and complicated to do.
Backpacks are incredibly
difficult and expensive
to simulate, her tamagotchi
on her backpack.
I definitely fought
for that Tamagotchi.
- One of the things
we really wanted to land
with Jacob as a character
is that he's a really good
hearted guy.
All right, so there's my under
drawing, so now I'll go ahead,
and do the ink drawing.
- The eyes are so important.
They're so expressive,
and cats have that kind of way
where when they're focused
on something, they kind of
get this, like, tunnel vision,
and it's fun creating that,
on like an animated character.
- This is probably
my favorite
phase of the drawing,
which is when I'm
adding shadows.
Not only because I
like how they look,
esthetically, but
they're also perfect
to cover some mistakes
that I've done.
- Sometimes when I'm drawing
a character's expression,
I can't help but
like try to make it myself,
they're all giggling
at the Oscar’s butt.
That's the idea
for this drawing.
- And one of things that I love
about animation
is how deeply collaborative
it is.
Hundreds of people
working for years on this
one thing.
- So excited about the Oscar
that he's leaping forward.
- Now I'm just noodling.
Okay, I'm done.
- I drew Jacob Holland,
one of the main characters
from The Sea Beast,
holding an Oscar.
He seems quite happy with it.
- This image was
what came to my mind.
In my mind,
it was father holding his son
and the son holding the Oscar.
So it was, it's
a double victory for him.
- Meilin would be over
the moon.
She would be so excited
to be holding that heavy,
naked gold man
she would have poofed into
a panda out of excitement.
- Over 400 people
worked on this movie,
and that means so much
that it's being appreciated,
not just out in the world,
in theaters,
but also by The Academy.
So thank you.